this is Alaska the largest state in the
nation with some of the most remote
wilderness and extreme conditions in the
world from as far south as the Inside
Passage
to as far north as the Arctic Circle
Alaska State Troopers protect the people
and wildlife of the frontier state only
386 men and women patrol an area nearly
3 times the size of Texas here
unforgiving terrain mixed with a
big-city crime make for a dangerous
combination one thing that's a little
bit different about our version of law
enforcement is that when we go on patrol
when we contact people we know a few
things we know that they will have guns
they will have knives and they'll know
how to use them this is Alaska everybody
has a gun in their car because there's
hunting year-round up here for different
animals of different species so I assume
every car has a firearm and a door
weapon licensed gun owners can legally
carry a concealed weapon in Alaska
that's a danger to troopers whether they
are on Highway Patrol or on the game
trail and for wildlife troopers
enforcing game regulations is no walk in
the park either you know it would be
easy to go out and go out fly to a kill
site look at it go that's something died
here and turn around and leave we don't
do that you know we go out we dig into
it a lot of times these big game
violations they're maggot infested
they're extremely nasty
they'll gag the best of us but troopers
don't have to patrol the wilderness to
come in contact with Alaska's wildlife
sometimes big game can be an
occupational hazard as we
come in two different seasons in Alaska
we get more and more moose on the
roadways a large bowl can be 1200 pounds
and you hit that at 50 miles an hour let
alone if you hit it when you respond to
something at 80 to 100 miles an hour
fatalities can definitely occur in
winter roads in the towns can be covered
in snow and in much of Alaska they're
non-existent so troopers use any means
necessary to go where they're needed
most snow machines ATVs boats even
helicopters and airplanes that's part of
the danger that a lot of folks don't
realize is just responding to what we do
on a daily basis Alaska means the nation
and aircraft accidents we fly everywhere
whether they're on a search-and-rescue
mission or investigating crime in the
villages troopers often patrol alone and
backup can be hours or even days away
some of our villages don't have any law
enforcement presence in them at all were
the only folks that respond we're it
while many Native Alaskan villages have
voted to ban alcohol abuse is widespread
and it fuels violent crime in their
communities
mr. probably human drinking today I can
smell you from here okay let's think you
got I cut or less like your tooth came
through the bottom what was going on
where were you at you know alcohol is a
huge problem out here and that's why the
state troopers in Alaska have a special
team to do nothing but try and prevent
drugs and alcohol from getting out to
the village it's it's just devastating
I was drinking alcohol and I heard it
some people that I wasn't supposed to
heard what we do isn't like what you can
see on cops where they Pig pile somebody
and put them in handcuffs I mean we
don't we don't work that way here and
keeping a certain amount of fairness and
any law enforcement is paramount out
here it takes on a whole new meaning
because it's not uncommon out here to
have to arrest somebody one day and then
when they're out a day or two or three
days later go knock on their door and
say hey I need help my boats dock if you
do anything that makes me nervous
this is the warning there will not be
any in the future I'll just take action
okay everything works differently in
Alaska and no one knows that better than
Alaska's best and bravest I'm kind of an
adventure seeker that guy wouldn't be
here if I didn't love it anybody who's
interested in state troopers that are
tighten up their seat belts it's
certainly been a wild ride for us